how's it goin breasts welcome back hey
hey what are you doing okay good
we're playing lost oh [ __ ] start that on
the floor start that getting with some
mode strike that kill you get so it's
not that that's not how he goes I think
maybe what is this mom okay I see you
later what happened here I don't I don't
I think we're done here
yeah we're done we're done let's go but
the thing is he went here no I don't
think it's entirely safe
oh he's scaring me I don't like the
shadows
huh no what happened
you just spontaneously exploded goddamn
door
rest in peace door rest in peace damn
it's a shame me it likes a little bit
when the scares happen I know what's up
with that but it's a shame in Brazil
Abed are we going back here seriously
hmm maybe we have to I like that it's
not linear but sometimes it's a little
too complicated for me at least I it's
it well that did the job oh no what
there now [ __ ] how did I see it's like
splashing and round like a [ __ ] magic
card right now now what did we do we
should not fall down there again
okay that's locked oh we can go in here
so tell me what's up no nobody little
bladder that's ugh I thought we were
done with this [ __ ] Danielle come on
all right bye-bye cheap I can it's so
much that [ __ ] care
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna drow I care I lie down
yeah there's too much water I can't even
turn on my lantern I don't have oil
anyway oh yes I actually have alright
this is actually kind of car I just hope
the spider doesn't come or whatever it
is
I'm so scared I should just give up
none of my watch can you stop biting my
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] which way they're gonna they'll
kick a lot a couple I think about it all
they do it up everybody for a good buddy
give all units way this way this way
this way
[ __ ] hate em run fast and block the
path how the [ __ ] my black power
please don't make me do that again
I want to play with our sounds I wanna
play without sound
[ __ ]
oh oh here is I furnish thank Jesus
thank Jesus so bad at making decisions
[ __ ] me [ __ ] the door I can
keep running keep running brother yeah
brother yeah brother yeah brother
come on you kidding yes ja stop
oh right up that's pretty impressive huh
don't worry about it you can we can I
don't know dad knows that was pretty
[ __ ] unnerving I gotta lie oh thank
god that's over
[ __ ] water yeah [ __ ] water
I'm never going new what is this never
go near water again hey boy
nice nice baby doing
be able to stare it's step hi babe
that's okay hello oh thank god a vagina
I feel so much better now okay
I didn't find anyone where are they I
just wanted to [ __ ] sit here for a
while
they must blow up the pipe connections a
long time for you this time but if [ __ ]
were you
nah it was terrible it was like things
everywhere
don't worry about hits just focus on get
together here
alright so father I love you I hate you
baby
alright stay here don't go anyway let's
go ahead here oh that was terrible
yeah thank God all right that's this the
other mayhem the light explained I don't
I don't know
is it really you know I don't
[Music]
it's this really long loading screen and
I literally have nothing TVs turning out
Wow
that chair was not supposed to hey God
mr. chair Thank You patty
I like your face today all right thank
you that's nice okay
make out like a little snack see today
if I may say so myself
one two no all right that's fine
hello nice oh hello dear diary my mommy
never wanted to talk about the head and
safe behind the painting I'm not even
allowed to touch the metal door I'm on
this it's no good to go in there there
is an English patch for this game so
don't be all like I just haven't had
time to install it and I'm fine with not
perfect grammar as long as you I know
that they try to fix it ah another note
dear diary my mom had locked the metal
door with a key mommy never says for the
kiss it's [ __ ] here hey it's a cute
door how do I open this a cha another
one hey I'm trying to read that box
don't be mean ah box what did I say how
can I block you what can I do about you
there we go I don't know how you opened
it maybe my husband helped you out but
it's an emergency I place to keep you
hind one of those books in the bedroom
but don't go in the basement one of the
workers like that he may be well he was
haunted by something I don't know I just
hope that you don't open it need to open
it well I have to
we had the books in the bedroom behind
the books in the bedroom which back
which one of your books was it a video
Russia it was I needed to share ah ha
why are you upside down I don't know I
was drunk all right coughing I don't
brakes ah there it is yeah ah ok wait I
have the basement key but not the key to
the okay I guess we go here and find the
key shut up don't worry about it ok
let's go
Oh oh no no no no no no no no no no no
[ __ ] Bow Wow you're not a lien yeah
although you try to hide you try to hide
[ __ ] you up I [ __ ] your mama that night
how's the battle [ __ ] I like that
alright follow this no stop new you
better shut up you better shut up
follow the parody oh hell no what do I
do now
okay I'll just hide he is [ __ ]
everywhere isn't he
[Music]
what it's gotta be something in here
okay oh I got the king high last time I
saw a little child and woman they told
me that was something leaking from his
[ __ ] but there was nothing wrong with
it then I went again but they locked the
door I was stuck in here I screamed but
they can't hear me
did they leave I've been stuck here for
two days now everything hurts especially
my nipples it feels almost like my
body's uncontrollable they locked me
away for a reason
the reason for the treason I just want
them
I don't even why I look 3 are you
[ __ ] kidding me come on don't look at
it
he's he just follows me everywhere I
don't even know what I did I didn't know
the barrel was his mother I mean [ __ ]
her don't [ __ ] me
oh that ass is so nice seriously he must
have got an implants Oh a barrel died
here
that's a barrel graveyard ah ah ah [ __ ]
that
you can't follow me here is way too
stupid and sexy I'm out of here
[ __ ] hate basements where the hell I
was I
okay you [ __ ] [ __ ] Betty told him
where I was to [ __ ] the basement
how lock this good he'll see Emma that
house all right we got our key
we'd better press says some man storage
key I don't even know where that goes oh
maybe over here it's a lot of mech to go
to the [ __ ] storage oh this was
[ __ ] open all along well [ __ ] I guess
the storage is outside then or maybe in
here no it's outside hi breasts
I'm gonna have to end it here but like
I'm favorite if you enjoyed subscribe to
become a Brett today and I'll see you
next episode of forevermore I make sales
and brothers I know
[Music]
yeah that's fashionable oh yeah boobs
yeah